endlich so richtig spiel aber ich
verstehe dich kummer hier ist das ding
was mir energie beschert das ist gerade
dieses gelb es ist nacht junge es ist
nacht war jetzt ich dachte kann was mir
kämpft gezeigt hat irgendwo hier ist ein
licht level wo ist das weiß ich nicht
irgendwo das leid level und wenn nacht
ist dann ist es leid level relativ
gering und ich verstehe nicht warum das
trotzdem leuchtet ich weiß nicht
vielleicht kann ich mir auch eine
künstliche sonne machen dass wir auch
cool gut der legt sich weiterhin wenn
jetpack auch komischerweise ich weiß
nicht warum
und da hinten läuft das auch langsam
das läuft auf jeden fall ist gut so dass
ich drei carbon platten aber so leute
was ich sagen wollte da oben ist mein
solar ding das versorgt das hier mit
energie also die energie wird in der
welt box gespeichert
ein kabel davon von der welt box kann
das hier machen aber zwei kabel davon
geht nicht aber hier wenn das da direkt
dran ist dann gehts verstehe es nicht
kann körper kenne nicht länger als 1
leiten oder woran liegt das jetzt
verstehe ich gar nicht gut
ich muss mich jetzt auch erstmal nicht
mehr beschäftigen ersten zukunft muss
das machen
ich schaue erst mal ganz kurz wie ich
mir jetzt hier den rotary rotary den so
da brauche ich erstmal warten hat wahns
maschinen blog advanced maschinen blog
das macht diese golem worker die das
ganze dann immer besser in felder und so
wenn man offline ist meine akkus gleich
alle glaube ich zwei carbon platten
brauche ich habe ich auf jeden fall
machine blog habe ich auch etwas scheu
hast du da brauche ich verschiedene
ärzte wolf r 3 die feineren und an
verschiedene ärzte hier drei gefahren
und dann nehme ich einfach zwei kupfer
oder was war dann noch zwei bronze
hessen habe ich genau die sachen haben
muss mich in bronze ich glaube braucht
sagte kopper da bronze genug bronze
ein tipp hin
ich weiß nicht ob ich genau die sachen
brauchte manche sagen jetzt bestimmt
wieder hörbar browsergame alles stimmt
ich habe briefe mit shiny tintin als auf
dem rallye daisy jungs ich probiere das
jetzt einfach so ja drei jahren dann
nach oben geklatscht
da kriegt man auch andere kabel raus
mehr geht nicht klappt wohl dann doch
nicht so auf jeden fall die drei liefern
brauche ich auf jeden fall schon mal
zwei bronze brauche ich auch
ein tipp was da der unterschied zwischen
den beiden müssen quasi dann das ist ein
thema das ist ein element hey ich
verstehe dass gerade gar nicht was ist
der unterschied zwischen zwischen
was passiert wenn ich aus fragezeichen
drücke gar nichts oder wie freude hilft
mir so de bronze fahren mache ich mit
kopftuch man das ist alles so
kompliziert
also es ist nicht kompliziert aber es
ist einfach so ich war voll viele
verschiedene kopper kupfer im komm ich
probiert erst mal rum dass ich diese
scheiße da irgendwie krieg auf jeden
fall brauche ich eine menge ärzte jetzt
erst mal wieder daran
jetzt sehen wir die wieder raus ich
brauche ich zurzeit das man nicht so
eisenbahn nehmen indem ich mit silber
nämlich mitglied nämlich mit liegt
nämlich nicht mit einigen nicht so und
jetzt muss ich ja irgendwie dieses
denken kriegen wir das nicht irgendwie
doch nicht
sinn habe ich erstmals in herz in barren
habe ich zehn waren
ist doch silber einfach oder ist genauso
aus wie silva ich freue mich auf diese
habe ich kenne keinen sinn
ich habe hier alles aber ich habe keinen
sinn oder was ich meine leute
ich schaue jetzt mal ganz kurzen andere
kisten
ich nehme mir nichts aus ich gucke ja
nur ein nicht verändern ja nix aber ich
schau mal zum beispiel ganz kurz park
einfach rein wie bei dem sinn aussieht
das sind da seht ihr übrigens jetzt
kleinen golems politischen partners in
kisten wird bei mir alles noch kommen
das bag hat ja auch schon zehnmal so
verfolgen wie ich oder 1000 war hat noch
mehr kein ding wollte den seine ganzen
kissling gestellt stetten da betreten
verboten während meiner pause
ok dann darf da nicht drauf weg kein
ding dann komme ich jetzt mal ganz kurz
rein
ich gucke ja nur die kiste beruhigt euch
freunde die jetzt wiederum hält am 9
mir wurden kühe geklaut das park wurde
ein turm geklaut ich gucke ja nun die
kiste ich glaube ja nix könnt ihr euch
auch gerne angucken silva silbereisen
barren geht er doch keinen sinn
referent silva silber ist silber nichts
in dem spiel
die den ganzen ärzte drin auf jeden fall
aber er hat auch keinen wert kein zins
kann es denn sein dass wir alle keinen
sinn haben und ich meine was ist richtig
zwischen silva und sinn weil das sieht
genau gleich aus einfach verstehe ich
nicht pflege mai enden
was ist der unterschied zwischen zinn
und silber
schauen wir dass es kurz an diese mittel
ist komisch in zukunft mixed mitteln
bronze barren kupfer zinn
wieso wieso warum nich wahr was ist da
der unterschied wie kriege ich so'n
scheiß mixed metal in gold hin
ich gucke jetzt im internet nach alter
mixed metal minecraft technik quickie ja
das brauche ich jetzt gerade rief einen
bronze da ist jedoch anders danke dass
ihr das keiner sagt hier wie von iron
curtis falsche
tadaa warum sagt mir das keiner so den
habe ich auf jeden fall schon mal im
internet stets was never in dem spiel
ansicht drin
fehlanzeige quatsch sprach ja keine
maschinen zudem muss jetzt erstmal in
das dings tun im kompressor mir nicht
ein kompressor in denen doch doch ein
kompressor
ein kompressor da war auch noch in
sachen da noch 750 dings für euch alle
kann ich wieder zurück zum dank ihr habt
mir entscheidende arbeit geliefert
carbon platten habe ich ach mensch leute
was wollte ich etwas was tun oder das
technik paket so dann habe ich diese
beiden sachen hier auf jeden fall schon
mal dann habe ich dir und dem
maschinenbau habe ich auch wo ist der
maschine blog dass der mich im blog ich
glaube ich brauche aber noch eine zweite
maschine und trinken
perfekt
ja nicht auf mails retter und 37
refinery noch 14 und major so dass
rogers mit meinem rennen
jacada funktioniert jetzt macht sport im
workshop webpage man mir vor sorgen bei
den anderen sachen nicht hier nicht halt
roce remains were so ja er hat sogar
energie will ich euch gern beweisen
obwohl abgesehen von da ist es erstmal
egal
läuft alles so und dann kommen wir auch
direkt zur nächste sache die ich machen
wollte
und zwar einen taktischen firma das
glaube ich schon immer ganz gut bei kev
der hieß hennef nach
ich mag nur kess vom stil her hier wird
was der baut und so den doch induction
fur das war das match in köln ist ja was
hat eigentlich hätte der wasserenergie
der motion glasfaserkabel danach werden
wir uns hier an machen freunde daran
zaubern wird nach und nach alles kommt
so induction furness muss er den
actionfilm ist so wie ich gebe das mal
so eine muss ich gucken
kopper electric furness advents
maschinen blog fick dich du musst noch
einmaleffekte ich meine kamera sie im
moment alle wenn die alles mache ich
auch erstmal ein stopp als ich glaube in
vier minuten mache ich ein stopp dann
geht's erstmal ohne verein weiter ich
habe gerade einfach voll bock auf dem
deswegen will ich jetzt noch weiter
aufnehmen und ihr kriegt jetzt e3 papst
täglich erstmal immer noch nicht weiß
nicht ob es immer noch so ist
bis dann irgendwann noch zwei parts
machen das werde ihr empfinden weil
ganze diese zwölf tage blauer vorbei
habe ich ja schon tausend mal gesagt et
cetera pp sieht cool aus mit dem gras
und ich wollte hier noch die türen beim
an ich wollte so viel machen ich hab so
bock hier darauf einfach gut
ein need another
radwan ist eine schiene block dann heißt
wieder zurück und ansonst maschinen
machine da es zwei carbon platten das
heißt dass ich habe keine wirklich will
kohl das glaube ich nie habe ich echt
nicht
ich muss noch kohle hier einpacken oder
auch nicht oder nektar wo muss ich dann
noch die krone auf einen blick wenn man
wirklich denn mal cool dass das einfach
moment ist mich aber graviert
auch kohle in pulver reiser war das in
die kohle mails rater doch hier war ich
denn mit mails ray gepackt da hab ich
doch im management diese klappen das
nicht
es funktioniert das hat er nämlich sich
aufgeladen oder doch jetzt funktioniert
auch das sagt alles ein bisschen aber
wieso ist er bei mir so langsam hat er
einfach keine energie oder macht er zu
wenig energie ich mein bett ging das
doch extrem schnell
vielleicht sollte ich doch ein bisschen
daran herum spielen an der
energieversorgung vielleicht wär auch
eventuelle glasfaserkabel besser obwohl
jetzt geht es ja von der schnelligkeit
ein bisschen aber es ist trotzdem
ärgerlich dass es so langsam ist
dann kommen wir hier 1 wir sollten das
so lange freude schreibt immer warum das
so lange dauert der könnte sich mit
sicherheit mehr speed holen acht erholt
sich die ganze zeit schon mehr speed
deswegen da muss ich grad aufladen
so habe ich doch jetzt herausnehme geht
er dann wieder runter von impfung speed
er ich weiß nicht ich lasse das einfach
mal da drin cool das kam mir nie genug
von kriegen wie ich hier so erfahre was
so ihr euch beide mussten einander
turnier dann kriege ich eine rocker bon
mesh die zuschauer ein und dann kriege
ich in die richtung
1 marrakesch ich brauche aber zwei davon
aber einer habe ich schon von daher ist
das jetzt egal was ich da mache dann
habe ich halt eine zu viel
auch noch daran nicht du so zwei carbon
platten habe ich schon mal für den für
den ding für ihn ist also da brauch ich
wieder so einen mix blabla
das war aus praktischen trick von ist
ein krieg ich wieder ein bisschen mehr
los ich schon aufgeladen glaube ich aber
wo ist die energie nähte praxis gerade
ja okay es geht ja jetzt auch vor
schnelligkeit
also der dell macht das grab schon durch
verstehe ich warum das hier nicht mit
zwei sachen geht ach nee das geht dann
nur mit dem mit dem pulver der es wieder
aufmacht ja gut passt ich brauche noch
dieses ding und bin brauche ich noch so
erweisen könnte mir draußen nehmen das
heißt sagt um eine mobile aufnahme wohl
automatisch angehalten ja leute dann
würde ich sagen mach ich jetzt mal ganz
kurz zu jasids komische geräusche mal
was ich immer total außer fassung wird
das cliq freundlich wird mich bedanken
für diese folge
wir sind beim nächsten mal wieder wenn
es dann wieder heißt weiter mit viel zu
bieten jetzt wird sich nur noch um
beatrice gekümmert ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr eine positive bewertung abgeben
würde das heißt mir das zeigt mir dass
es euch gefallen hat und dass ihr mehr
von the beast volt und allgemein vom
mega projekt und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder ciao